freaky head monsters bounty hunters that
don't stand a chance and don't forget
this action oh yeah do that thing with
the tongue that I like the witcher's
part one of season three is out and with
it the beginning of the end of Henry
Cavill as geralt no God please no so
while I dry my tears I decided to put
this video together explaining some of
the biggest moments its relation to the
books and what we can expect in part two
and don't worry there won't be any book
spoilers beyond episode 5 until I get to
my spoiler section which I'll give you
warning for in that I'll also have a
breakdown of the part 2 trailer so grab
some ale and put on your favorite valdo
record because I plan on getting
pregnant tonight much of season 3
focuses on several major players
searching for princess of sintra Slash
Witcher slash Elder blood Haver cirilla
Fiona Ellen Rhiannon she's in high
demand for various reasons first we have
King verdania vizimir II he's made a
secret deal with nilfgaard that if they
were to find and hand over Siri first
red Daniel will be left untouched and
given to Maria as a vassal State this
forces Philippa and dixtra to take
Extreme Measures and kill the queen
staging it to look as though she were
killed by nilfgaard in the books however
Queen Hedwig never loses her head and
vizimir actually wants Siri dead so that
she isn't captured by player number two
Emperor Emir VAR amress AKA The White
Flame at the end of season 2 it was
revealed that the emperor was indeed
Siri's father the cursed Dooney who you
may remember from season 1 and the law
of surprise he'd obviously want to get
his daughter back but why then do we see
him burning paintings of her why would
he want his history of her erased I'll
save that for my spoiler section the
third player is Francesca find the bear
Queen of the elves of doll bluathana she
believes Siri is the hen akir or the
savior of elves who will lead them to
their rightful home and finally there
are the wraiths of morehog also known as
the wild Hunt they're led by its king
aired in Brach glass who in season two
told Siri that her rightful place is
with him he and his Riders will make a
brief appearance in part one but what
Siri is really afraid of is how the wild
Hunt was able to Traverse back to their
world since the last we saw them Siri
had left them in their own to understand
this we have to go back to the
conjunction of the Spheres at Great
cataclysmic event that occurred over
1500 years before the main events of The
Witcher in which several parallel
universes merged into one when this
happened the elves of the wild Hunt lost
control of the eternal's gate a gate
which allowed them to travel in great
numbers between worlds thus they had to
find a different way to travel using
portals and specially trained Mages that
could only transport a small group of
riders at a time and these Riders took
the form of a Cavalcade of specters
since we saw in season 2 that Siri
possesses this power to travel between
these worlds you can guess why this king
would want her now the search for Siri
is set against the backdrop of impending
or essentially you have the northern
kingdoms pitted against nilfgaard to the
South geralt Siri and yennefer find
themselves stuck in the middle while
simultaneously trying to protect Siri
throughout part 1 they're chased by a
sorcerer known as reince who is secretly
working for a sorceress named Lydia van
bredavoort in the books reince Works
directly with Lydia's quote-unquote Lord
but in the show he demands to know who
Lydia's Master is we can piece together
from the show that Lydia's Master is
none other than vilgafort's a mage
working with nilfgaard but it's
important to note what she says to
Ryan's that working with nilfgaard isn't
the same as working for nilfgar she and
her master are working towards something
much bigger her earrings are made of
scarlet ammonite the same material of to
saya's bracelet that was gifted to her
by vilgaforce hilgaforce himself also
carries with him a Scarlet ammonite
necklace this particular mineral is only
found in Western rodania the same place
geralt found those girls locked in
Castle volpane but the this isn't the
only thing that connects the rebel Mage
with nilfgaard there's also the painting
of the first landing which vilgavort
says is his favorite it's kind of ironic
that this is his favorite painting since
it's all about the formation of the
Brotherhood when vilgaforts appears to
be instrumental in its undoing and it
just so happens the setting of that
painting was where yennefer was
transported to when she went through the
corrupted portal but by the time
yennefer and geralt put all of this
together it's too late Taryn the girl
geralt rescued revealed that Ryan's had
been working with someone she recognized
from aratuza and a woman with a quote
funny voice this funny voice belongs to
Lydia who lost her jaw and now uses
magic to keep its appearance in the book
Lydia was a sorceress slash personal
assistant to vilgafort and lost her jaw
to a cursed artifact that vilgaforts had
asked her to work on with both Lydia and
isea getting jewelry from him it can be
safe to assume he's playing both of them
something Philippa refers to as a quote
poison that slowly kills you yennefer
will try to contact Isaiah and warn her
of vilgafort's plan geralt and yennefer
came to aratuza located on the island of
thaned in the hopes of uniting the
Brotherhood and the northern kingdoms
against this Southern nilfgaard threat
they also plan to expose the Mage
stregabore while strugivore definitely
is a villain he says he never conducted
experiments on those girls could care
less about Siri and although he hates
half-breeds has no intention of
murdering them all the night before the
conclave is to commence a delicate power
play emerges between various members in
attendance episode 5 titled the art of
Illusion shows us the banquet sequence
multiple times each time adding more
context even the song valdo and his crew
seeing States all is not as it seems
it's here that geralt's neutrality is
tested dixtra and Philippa want him to
disclose the location of Siri and join
the north bonus points if you caught
geralt's little jab at Philippa when he
says tonight a reference to her poly
morphing into an owl on the other hand
is a little more subtle not entirely
revealing his plans but hinting that he
and Jennifer should join alongside him
at aratuza after all he and vilgaforts
aren't that much different both are
orphans outcasts and both became better
men when they found someone they loved
but geralt has a deep fondness for The
Witcher principle of neutrality
neutrality I won't get you a statue
but it'll certainly happen keeping you
alive witchers traditionally do not take
sides in political or social conflicts
with geralt saying I shall respond to
events ah depth of the world as it
changes where this gets sticky is when
his neutrality gets in the way of
protecting Siri earlier in the season he
said this I
understand Siri
even if it cost me my life he may need
to choose a side and forego his
neutrality if it means protecting her
this will definitely be tested in part
two Siri herself will also deal with her
own internal struggle and this Spurs
from her Visions early in episode 2 Siri
has a vision of a redanian soldier
Applegate getting hit by an arrow and
obviously she wants to warn him but
Jennifer is quick to stop this saying I
don't know either
changing Destiny is a weighty business
Siri does not like this if she can
prevent someone from dying and change
their fate why not help but what Siri
doesn't understand is how her decisions
could alter the future and make things
even worse you saved one
and the consequences likely damned 100
others in exchange what Jennifer is
trying to say is that we don't know the
future by Saving this guy Siri could be
starting a sequence of events that gets
even more people killed Jennifer knows
this firsthand because her decision to
save one prisoner in season two set the
entire Brotherhood against the North and
even the Brotherhood against each other
two other things I want to bring
attention to is Siri embracing herself
as a Witcher and the rekindling of
geralt and yennefer's relationship at
the beginning of the Season geralt gave
yennefer the silent treatment yennefer
betrayed he and Siri after bringing Siri
to this shattered black door at the
behest of the demon volathmir who
promised to give yennefer her powers
back in her defense she didn't know how
special Siri was especially to geralt
and will later try to make amends by
sacrificing herself as a vessel for
volathmir to inhabit and in the process
saving Siri so at the beginning of the
Season she's really trying to get back
into geralt's good books at the same
time geralt lives with the fact that
he'll never know if yennefer's love for
him is true in season 1 in order to save
yennefer's life he made a wish with the
Jinn that bound their Fates together the
books nor series ever say what these
exact words are but it calls into
question if their love is real or simply
magic as fate would have it geralt
awakens the morning after the banquet to
the shouts of an unknown woman demanding
the gates to the Great Hall be secured
this is the start of an event known as
the thaned coup and judging by dixtra's
knife against geral's throat he'll be
having to pick a side very soon I guess
you could say it's team dick vs team
prick but before I divulge anything more
this is your warning as I'll be getting
into book and trailer spoilers please
note that the show can and has deviated
from the books so things in part two may
not line up exactly with what's written
unlike previous Witcher Seasons since
three is split up into two parts we get
a juicy trailer right at the end and it
looks like geralt makes it out of his
sticky situation with dixtra as he can
be seen here along with yaskir fighting
some nilfgaardian soldiers in the books
geralt is arrest by dixtra and sent to
garstan the palace on thaned to await
trial as we zip through some close-ups
of our characters we get to what I
really want to talk about a
confrontation between geralt and this
unseen figure wielding a staff
considering geralt tells this person he
won't choose sides and in the part one
finale he also told vilgaforts he
wouldn't choose this is likely
vilgaforts in the book geralt does
battle a staff wielding vilgaforts and
loses with the Mage sparing geralt's
life partially to catch up to Siri in a
shot a bit later on we can basically
confirm it's him we'll see this green
Sparkle from his sword and in the games
there are certain enchantments and
elixirs that can cause the blade to
Flame or glow but I think this is just a
gem shining in the light later on it
looks as though this battle makes its
way outside onto the beach where
vilgafort's staff manages to break
geralt's sword and hat I mentioned
earlier the emperor's intentions with
Siri in the books he plans to marry his
own daughter due to ifly's prophecy
interpreting it to believe that if he
were to have a child with Siri it would
be the one prophesies to rule the world
vilgafort's allies himself with the
emperor believing it to be the best way
to acquire Siri and use her blood to
amplify his own magical power he's also
promised by the emperor of the northern
kingdoms you probably saw this image of
Siri in a desert if we're going by the
books this is after she flees through a
portal in the tower of Tor Laura and
ends up randomly in the korath desert
there she'll meet a unicorn named little
horse that will help her out of the
desert it's here that she'll experience
pyromantic Visions which we'll see here
now what I want your help on is this
image here it appears to be a sorceress
using lightning to attack nilfgaardian
soldiers and elves in the garstan
courtyard with this woman here using
magic to defend against these lightning
attacks who is this Mage and who's the
Mage protecting these soldiers below my
guess is that it's either Philippa to
Saya or Tris but I want to hear your
theories in the comments below with part
1 coming to an end I now handed over to
you what did you think of part one and
how do you think they'll handle part two
thanks for watching and please be sure
to like And subscribe for more mad takes
you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember I am beloved by all and
have no enemies